(glass smashes)
(tense music)
(upbeat music)
- Forget Benji.
And to hell with that phone.
Give me your hand.
- The train's coming.
- Pick it up, pick it up, pick it up,
pick it up, pick it up, pick it up,
pick it up, pick it up, pick it up.
- Your hand, now.
- Pick it up!
- Hey man, I'm thinking maybe...
- Like you said, I'm not a killer,
but this,
is about her.
- I'm telling you.
- I'm scared.
I'm very scared of what
you would do to her.
Maple almond latte?
Two Stevia.
Two tablespoons of peanut oil.
Could've gone either way.
He's lied about so many things.
Who knew, the peanut allergy was real.
Benji has to go.
The books are safe, basement
is 100% corpse free,
can't burn the body in daylight anyway
so the least Benji can
do is wait in the car
for a little while.
- I like who I am with you Joe.
♪ You can see it in my eyes ♪
♪ I'm an animal ♪
♪ Coming out of nowhere ♪
♪ Take a breath and say your prayers ♪
- Sorry I didn't call,
is it okay if I come in?
♪ Coming out of nowhere ♪
♪ I'm an animal ♪
♪ Take a breath and say your prayers ♪
♪ You play your game ♪
♪ I take my time ♪
♪ You take your aim ♪
♪ Commit your crime ♪
♪ I won't back down ♪
♪ Won't come away ♪
- [Beck] Too rough for you Goldberg?
- [Joe] Not at all.
♪ I'm an animal ♪
♪ Coming out of nowhere ♪
♪ Take a breath and say your prayers ♪
- Hello, how old were you
when this was taken, Beck?
And what is Peach doing with it?
- Hello Joe.
Sorry I'm so wet.
- [Joe] I know what it's like
to be in love with you Beck.
This is not what love looks like.
This isn't how love behaves,
this is the work of a sick mind.
Let's call it what it is, perversion.
Now I understand why Peach is
setting you up for failure,
she's not threatened by you,
she's obsessed with you.
- You know I love you forever, right?
- [Joe] She wants to watch you, have you,
control you like she controls
every other piece of her life.
She wants you all to herself.
Beck, you've got a stalker.
This is why I took up jogging.
♪ You must run and hide ♪
♪ For the hunter he seeks ♪
♪ With his devilish pride ♪
(eerie music)
- Uh-oh, she's dead.
Of course she's dead, she fell.
That's right, she fell.
An accident.
Happens all the time, she
was running and she fell,
into a rock, over and over again.
Okay let's be real, she was
attacked, someone attacked her,
but maybe they had a good reason, right?
You ever think of that, detective?
The universe has a funny
way of keeping us humble.
That beating was karmic, I know it.
I did a bad thing today,
(phone vibrating)
but for a good reason,
and if there's any justice in the world,
you are the reward for all my suffering.
Hey you.
- Oh Joe thank God.
Peach was attacked in Central
Park in broad daylight.
I'm headed to the ER now.
- She's alive?
I need to patch up, focus,
get back in the game.
(laughing)
I love you, you know.
I'll double back for that.
How long is she going to
stand there staring at you?
- [Peach] Um, I swear it
was here, I just used it.
Oh.
- [Joe] Another thing I keep learning,
things can always get worse.
- [Peach] You want this?
- [Male] I don't have one.
- [Peach] Okay.
Here he comes, big daddy.
- [Joe] Oh Beck, I'm so boned,
but not as boned as Raj is about to be.
- [Raj] Oh, God, that's interesting.
- You know deep down
she's never gonna love you
the way you love her.
- Stop saying that.
- She's never gonna do it.
You can't have her.
- Stop saying it!
(gunshot)
(tense music)
- I mean honestly Dr.
Nicky's been really helpful
dealing with my grief.
I think we need more stars,
they're in your office, right?
- Yeah.
Don't get me wrong, there's nothing wrong
with going to therapy, it's
just it's a bit troubling
when your partner hides
something from you.
Don't you agree, Dr. Nicky?
- I hear you Paul.
Not cool.
- Oh shit.
Hey man, did you,
did you want a bump?
- [Joe] Yeah, yeah.
- [Elijah] Whoa, bro.
(Elijah screams)
- Oh shit.
(tense music)
(panicked breathing)
My phone.
Must have dropped it in the subway.
- Huh.
- What the hell?
- Yeah.
Hey, I'm on my way bro.
- Ozma of Oz, and who
said anything about Joe?
- No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
(glass smashes)
Hey, Annika just texted,
she's totally freaking out,
something about her psycho roommate.
I'm gonna go check on her, all right?
I'll call you later.
Joe!
- Everything I have done
I have done for you.
- Even this?
- Even this.
- I know that I am better
with you than without you.
- Beck.
- Oh if you were in here this
would be our moment to kiss.
(Joe groans)
- Beck!
(distant screaming)
- Paco!
Paco thank God, I need your help.
Open this door right now.
Joe, he is downstairs and he's crazy.
- Joe?
- Paco, he has killed people.
He's gonna kill me.
Open this door right now!
Paco!
Open the door!
Open the door, please!
Please Paco, no!
No Paco!
- When Mooney locked me
in I learned a big lesson,
hide a spare key so you can
get out of the goddamn cage.
(panicked breathing)
(tense music)